hello everybody my name is Mark salami I
made my home oh it's so pretty
who are you I punched her I punched her
so hard she went into the ocean
it's a BDSM alligator a B D a semi Gator
it's it's a it's it's a gimpy Gator it's
a it's a [ __ ] it it's an Alec in / it's
it's a beet it's an alibi yes hey I'm
sorry I'm sorry that I punched the only
woman on this island hello
you like my horse oh I can walk with my
human legs oh I can try to not spill by
human coffee is this how hard it is to
actually human Oh key card the key cards
in my body mail see bit cuckoo bit mail
Seebeck wah ha ah baguette an Eiffel
Tower oh I'm not responsible for all
these deaths you know I'm not gonna be
labeled the murder just because I'm
rampantly booing off of make up that
baby caught a faceful um excuse me could
you get out of my horse just got a bow
you know every once in a while pay my
respects to the dead you know spill out
some coffee for those that we have lost
in this endeavor nut kick to the whoa
whoa sorry are you okay your leg doesn't
seem any bad no okay anyway I'm gonna go
to chuffing Tain's oh no she keeps your
skin soft and supple it also sounds a
lot like farts we French
put my castle on this hell yes I'm doing
all that with my brain I'm putting them
all pieces together
I'm charging up ooh what Santa here we
go right on your ding-dong whoa Santa
you'll come with me whether you like huh
losers
shut up Santa yep ha ha ha fits like a
glove
I Drive this car I can really oh yes
cinematic view for the car what am I
gonna do with it
where am I gonna drive it here I go
often what are you doing why do you have
a magic ranking why is there a fly why
is there a guy in an ice-cream sandwich
suit years left on earth what does that
even mean so make any sense yeah well
whatever screw you I don't know what you
killed [ __ ] yeah I'd like to think that
this is actually a whoa jeez okay
goodbye hello oh you want to put up your
dukes
well I'll warn you apparently I'm a
great ok you're dead now
excuse me sir where's I heard there was
a flash sale or is it fart sale
hey you get me you feelin me ok never
mind then the beam of light is not where
I was it's where I'm pooping and somehow
oh my god did he die oh he broke his
long neck oh ok
there's other controls get it get it man
yeah
hello can I trade on you yes oh you
gallop so silly there we go
you're welcome thank you I'm lady
I got a wha can you give me a wire I've
got a whole lot of wire
got some wire anybody want some why Wow
can I get the were lower it oh no oh
okay
let's try to get through it like this
yeah that's normal
mmm my normal human walking pose yes
have a good day lovely fellow humans
let me just join in my massive booty
through the turnstile well now on to
question a lot of things in life in fact
I live a very abnormal life so I don't
know I mean not this abnormal I'm not
stretching myself out with lotion every
night Oh exactly where I'm going
everybody get out of my way if you get
one of my TVs I swear to god I'm gonna
rip through all eyebrows not sir I'm
gonna rip your eyebrows out apparently
oh my balls I'm gonna give give give
Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff - can I
get some of this delicious Parfum my
[ __ ] that's so stupid
get it up oh [ __ ] back oh [ __ ] we're
getting the terminal ass extension back
it up okay try to make it like this now
whoa human [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah my windows over my husband his
whole time scream the bathroom
[Music]